[Music]
in this video we bring you the breaking
news about house of the dragon
hbo just announced on game of thrones
official twitter account
that game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon casted major roles
and picked season 1 directors
we are talking about the main characters
that are going to play a major role in
these prequels such as daemon and
rhaenyra targaryen
and alice and hightower just real quick
before we go into it
i know and understand that some of you
might not be too happy with the casting
for house of the dragon
but let me tell you this while the lead
cast is announced and confirmed
it's definitely not final yet you see
the game of thrones prequel starts
filming in about 40 days
and during the filming there might be
some changes if they don't prove to be
the best choice
for example during the first filming of
game of thrones
several actors major and minor were
replaced
daenerys targaryen was originally played
by thames in merchant
but she was replaced by emilia clarke
jennifer ely originally played kathleen
stark
but was replaced by michelle fairley in
other words if these lead actors do not
prove to be the best possible choice
they will be replaced during the filming
of house of the dragon
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022 it's based on
georgia
martin's book fire and blood vol 1 and
on mars yet unfinished fire and blood
vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhinera targaryen's son aegon
iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war miguel sapochnick
and ryan condell will serve as
showrunners and executive producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided
the kingdoms in two targaryens fought
targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
rhaenyra is one of the main characters
in the targaryen civil war at the heart
of the show
emma darcy is casted to play her the
cast nicole described her as king
viserys's chosen heir
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
the official description describes her
as the king's first born child she is of
pure valyrian blood
and she is the dragon rider many would
say that rhaenyra was born with
everything
but she was not born a man princess
rhaenyra targaryen cheered as the
realm's delight when she was young
and later called the half-year queen was
the first born child of king viserys the
first targaryen
reiner was king viserys is the first
only living child by his first wife
queen emma of house serene at the age of
eight she was made her father's heir
and grew up expecting to become the
first ruling queen of westeros
rhaenyra was a dragon rider whose mount
was cyrex
rhaenyra had her family's valyrian looks
varying her silver gold hair in a long
braid in the manner of queen visenya
targaryen
beautiful as a child rhaenyra was later
declared by her uncle prince daemon
targaryen to be the most beautiful
maiden in all the seven kingdoms
due to the lack of a male heir viserys
designated rhaenyra as his successor
therefore rhaenyra was the only female
targaryen to lay claim to the iron
throne in her own right
since she was raised as the designated
heir rhaenyra became quite pampered and
arrogant
but also gained practical governmental
experience
after rhaenyra's mother died her father
remarried
and had several sons with his second
wife alison of house hightower
even so viserys still publicly expected
his daughter to succeed him
and when he died his official will even
stated so
however rhaenyra's younger half-brother
aegon challenged her claim
he stated that the normal inheritance
laws of the andals
which formed the basis of the unified
law code in westeros called for male
preference primogeniture
meaning that a younger son would
rightfully inherit before an older
daughter
at the time of her father's death
rhaenyra was done dragonstone evading
the birth of her child
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her
until her own supporters in the red keep
were dead or imprisoned
and aegon ii's coronation had already
occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart the seven kingdoms
known as the dance of the dragons as it
was the only war in which both sides had
dragon riders
rhaenyra had two husbands and five sons
her first husband was laenor of house
valerian
son of the sea snake and her second
husband was her uncle daemon targaryen
the rogue prince
and there we come to the second
announced lead actor matt smith will
play daemon
george r martin revealed that daemon is
his favorite targaryen
so that tells you something about the
character hbo describes the character as
the younger brother to king viserys and
the heir to the tron
a peerless warrior and the dragonrider
daemon possesses the true blood of the
dragon
but it's said that whenever a targaryen
is born the gods toss a coin in the air
demon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lordly bottom and the rogue
prince had many titles throughout his
life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm
daemon was the most controversial man of
his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sir leonard valorian
and she was his third wife prince damon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister a dragon rider whose dragon
was characters
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and the narrow sea
daemon was a skilled warrior described
in the histories as dashing
daring and dangerous he was also
ambitious impetuous mercurial
immoral reckless and quick to take
offense he is described as being as
charming as he was hot tempered
daemon's most epic moment comes from the
most epic dragon battle
the battle above the god's eye between
two most dangerous warriors at that time
daemon and aemond targaryen and their
two dragons
which also were the strongest of all
vegar and characters
daemon challenged the aemond waiting for
13 days at harrenhal
until aemond stopped burning the
riverlands to come to face him
when characters attacked vulgar she
ripped upon his stomach and tore one of
his wings
but then characters fast and his jaws
surround her throat in death grip
these injuries forced them both to cease
flying
and as they tumbled through the water
below daemond dueled aemon to death
as he never fastened his saddle daemon
stood up on charaxes
and lapped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister through
aemon's eye and through his neck just a
second before hitting the water
the battle above the god's eye ended in
the deaths of both riders and both the
dragons
daemon was 49 when he died unlike
eamon's body however
demons was never found singers say that
daemon lived to spend the rest of his
days in secret with nettles
but most historians disagree last but
not the least
hbo also announced that olivia cook is
also lead actor
casted to play alice in hightower alice
in hightower is described as the
daughter of otto hightower
the hand of the king and the most calmly
woman in the seven kingdoms
she was raised in the red keep close to
the king and his innermost circle
she possesses both a courtly grace and a
keen political acumen
alice and hightower was a member of
house hightower who became the second
wife to king viserys the first targaryen
and therefore a queen of the targaryen
dynasty she was the daughter of seroto
hightower
who had been the hand of the king to
jahiris the first viserys the first
and later his grandson aiken ii she was
the mother of king aegon ii
queen hilina prince aymond and prince
daeron
alice and hightower was in many ways the
true leader of aegon ii's faction
during the dance of the dragons at first
young rainer and ellison got along well
but the rift grew between them as soon
as allison produced her own children for
viserys the first
and clearly wanted them to succeed to
the throne instead of her
ali sent bore viserys the first four
children aegon the second
aemon the one eye there on the daring
and helina who became the sister wife of
fagon ii
over the years of viserys since the
first reign despite his best efforts
a better rivalry grew between alice sent
and rainer at court
as well as between their rival factions
of supporters
in 111ac a great tourney was held at
king's landing
on the 5th anniversary of the king's
marriage to queen ellison
at the opening feast ellison wore a
green gown while princess rhaenyra
dressed in targaryen red and black
soon afterward their respective
followers started dressing in similar
colors and styles
to display their political allegiance
rhaenyra's faction the princess's
followers wore black clothing
in dallas satisfaction the queen's
followers wore green clothing
ultimately this inspired the nicknames
for the two factions the blacks and the
greens
visery is the first publicly and
repeatedly made the great lords of the
realms fair oats that rhaenyra would
succeed him on the iron throne
as the first ruling queen a matter of
hours after viserys the first died in
his sleep however
ellison staged a coup one that she had
been long planning to define details
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep
and ran to inform queen ellison protocol
dictated that the bells would be wrong
everyone notified and a raven sent to
dragonstone to summon the air princess
rhaenyra for her coronation
but ellie sent her daughter planes once
she saw her that husband's body she
sealed the room
and had the sermon thrown into the black
cells to ensure his silence
according to mushroom who was away with
rhaenyra targaryen on dragonstone alice
sent poisoned viserys's drink
true or not instead of announcing
viserys as the first death immediately
alison warned sir christian cole now
lord commander of the kingsguard
and together they called the small
council to discuss the succession
where plans were made to crown alice and
son prince aegon
instead of princess rhaenyra who had
been with serious
heir or isn't viserys drink true or not
instead of announcing viserys as the
first death immediately
alison warned sir christian cole now
lord commander of the kingsguard
and together they called the small
council to discuss the succession
where plans were made to crown alice
allison's son prince aegon
instead of princess rhaenyra who had
been with zerus
heir this started the targaryen civil
war which will be the key event of the
upcoming game of thrones prequel house
of the dragon
we also know the directors for the first
season in addition
to game of thrones sweater and miguel
sapoching who's serving a showrunner
along with ryan condol
the directing team will also include
claire kilner jira patel and greg
yatenys the first season is confirmed to
consist of 10 episodes
house of the dragon is coming thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one
peace
you